aujourd'hui on se penche sur quoi on put
du temps il est cassé plein de marge qui
a tout petit village dans cette vidéo
aujourd'hui une dizaine d sion great
merde c'est un jeu qu'on avait fait il
ya trois ou quatre mois un jeu qui était
en démo actuellement la version finale
est sorti j'avais envie d'y retourner
alors utilisé un sourire oui mais je me
lève pour pour m'échapper je me souviens
c'est que mon pote est décédé par terre
ecolutions dessus comme des grands mdp
val walbach et boum
mais non mais [ __ ] mais j'ai fait ce
qu'il fallait et j'ai ouvert le gaz dit
j'ai mis des étincelles et mi-live voilà
c'est vrai ça a marché
c'est tellement script et que si tu fais
le truc trop vite ça marche pas pour
être vont attendre d'entendre le garrot
venir quad c'est génial au aucun sens au
temps des lyssois sonic all apache ok on
se réveille
oh [ __ ] fatso mon gars what a redit
dans l'eau à temps mais convient de
nager dans une flaque raid c'est quoi ce
jeu comment on arrive dans l'appart ok
voilà ça samedi un truc je sais qu'à un
moment on fait ça et je crois qu'il
apparaît je vais je me chie dessus un
plus haut à delphi qui fait quoi il fait
il fait 10 degrés syndic n une esprit un
esprit pas loin s'il fait froid à quoi
un esprit jeune armes y avait un truc y
avait un truc là là on avait un truc
bouger trois mois après l'ouverture de
l'hôtel atlantis quelque chose c'était
quelque chose d'inexplicable trois
personnes se sont défenestrées de se
sont pendus mdm son suicide de sa nièce
bon bah ça va nous le savons il est têtu
dans sa propre chambre des conditions
inconnues et la police n'a pas su
retrouver les coupables
bon ben voilà on s'est dit et ce mec
c'est débuté en sachant mais il se venge
alors est ce qu elle s'occupait tu mets
le petit post-it sur la porte
pourquoi je peux pas courir plus tard
dans tous les jours peut courir c'est
pas normal mais qu eux
avec attention là de quoi est pas sorti
nos villas apparurent apparaît dans le
même endroit glauque voilà au [ __ ] je
te plains beat box soit plus de ça tu
vois un coup de couteau dans le dos sa
signature n'est pas mon gars on va se
fixer une plaque en métal sur le dos et
tu pourras pas nous planter pâte arcari
johnson 1991 à la cemex est débutée
voilà f y est comment sa copie c'est à
quai on se casse à quai après au quai à
quai alors mec cette vitesse de
déplacement et ce code
j'en ai marre de ce jeu voire des
dérouillées besoin d'une touche d'une
toge peut dire faut qu'il y ait une
touche faut qu'ils m'apprécient j'en ris
ou une touche de clavier ou moi j'ai
besoin d'une touche c'est la touche
shift pour courir s'te plaît ne me tue
on est dans de terre nouvelles et on va
essayer de se faufiler entre c'est un
peu au [ __ ]
non non le mec il vole quoi aux gens un
conduit mon gars est-ce que c'est aux
nobles ce mec soit fait capturer
vu la vitesse à laquelle il se déplace
vers l'est et le nord fogué en c1 est
pourri kidnappé ce gars sans difficulté
quoi aussi à une note une note relatifs
aux quais ou continue notre avancée dans
le jeu le plus cheap d'europe
oh la vache au verrouillé besoin d'une
touche c'est une clé oh mon dieu oh mon
dieu les lampes ce casque par une [ __ ]
les gens j'avoue que là j'en fait le
fait de lâcher si lentement fait tu
t'ennuies à l'escwa trouver une clé est
là haut la balle a juste pu taha le mec
a beau milieu quoi aller ça souffle tout
seul bordel dans nos studios eric
clavier est le meilleur ami de carrie
johnson vous savez j'ai encore du mal à
croire que je ne reverrais plus alors
parler de ce qu'on lui a fait au nom au
nom non je me suis bloqué ben je veux me
tirer une balle je vais pas refaire ce
jeu bordel
non mais je vais juste monté sur des
guerres pour aller sur une passe
[ __ ] ya beaucoup continuent et on
recommence de la wii avec le mec qui
passe je suis content de voir ok bon bah
je refais cette partie là allez way la
vidéo de la joie car i o fils alex il
faut que je fasse pour que je fais ce
passé que je me fasse tatouer gros issep
ce qu'une punch taris le chanteur on
s'amuse tellement dans cette vidéo
[ __ ] c'est assez la meilleure je crois
tu crois pas tu te diras pas ici sans
savoir tout ce qui s'est passé
eh ben dis le moi clairement sur une
note plus tard ça mais il a dit je
sortirai pas ici sans avoir appris
quelque chose je le crois mais je vais
plus attentionné à dos et carbon
attentionné mais qu'on a lu toutes les
notes mais n'y a pas plus attentionné
peut-être suis-je vraiment apprendre
quelque chose d'important
on va voir ça ça et le sous titre qui
parle pas mais plus tard j'ai fini de
lire voir des femmes dont le courage y
est je peux passer en plus tard mais
j'en ai ras bord et la veille à l'az
exceptionnel qui se meuvent le sort du
tunnel on sent du manoir on s'en va on
quitte le jeu ou lanceurs stones ont
fait une petite graine ou la vache non
c'est à dire qu'il est là l'équipe par
la mm20 screamer à je le vois rien je le
vois voyou pas moi je le prouve hu ont
la vache je peux pas parce que tu dis ya
un bout de la course poursuite
c'est un contentieux ap de ma vie
l'apache araujo but faucheux but tu
viens là ok ça rien fait à bientôt
j'espère le bouton comme ça on est sûr
ça lui fait un truc
ouah on a réussi après 128 bug alors on
est mort au nom à bienne potes qui s'est
ouverte dimanche qu'on veut sauter haut
laura concédant balade aulas lahoud a
gagné au moins dix minutes de marche sa
part dans les bois très bien vous
attendez c'est la musique heures stone
plus tard moderne
on va faire tout pour un joueur trop
bordel la vache ça fait du bien saboté à
finir le géologue serment dans ces
moments-là que j'adore mon métier ce que
je fais tous les jours ça me some
passionne de cause on retourne dans la
maison là c'est ça c'est ce qui est en
train de se passer en fait ok pense
qu'il faut qu'on aille à l étage qu'on
passe par ce petit couloir nouveau voilà
c'est la passion l'anjou pajot subi un
jeu qu'on se retrouve sur les
passerelles qu'il y avait au dessus la
bibliothèque peut pas dire je peux
toujours pas lire oh [ __ ] payante et
un avion journée bon de voir ces jeunes
ont pu pour rigoler fait depuis 24 mois
je crois que ça revient vite à j'allais
enfin m'amuser au monde où le bureau et
tout mais [ __ ] amidon mais ça doit
être super pour vous tous en accéléré
tout le monde lyon n'y a pas si les
angevins bla bla bla bla bla bla du
rouge partout
est-ce qu'ils sont pas beaux est ce que
ça soit sans quoi une petite entorse
d'ici là
je suis retenu je comprends rien je suis
mort espace quoi mieux vaut y aller mais
franchement envie de chialer
c'est une blague c'est une blague mon
gars dans mes mecs n'aurait la donne
c'est une blague grecque mais c'est quoi
cette journée assez bien merci
pour de vrai jamais avec son rêve après
ce qui vient de se passer si je perds
plus mag et leurs stocks mais je vais
humblot on va traverser des parties non
mais c'est pas grave mon grand aussi tu
savais ce qu'on vient de vivre nous tous
ensemble
c'est davantage que ça vous a plu c'est
le cas n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo on se
retrouve très bientôt dans une prochaine
bah voilà il ya des jours comme ça où
finalement tu aurais mieux fait de ne
pas te lever et de rester au lit sous sa
couette mais ça me regarde et on s'est
entraînés dans une prochaine vidéo audio
tout le monde porte est ouverte pis